[Music]
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
gazebo experience guys would you take a
minute and please join me under the
gazebo
of course referencing to our new h3
video that I hope everyone enjoyed the
catfish Mayo kit god bless you all thank
you to today our sponsors are Robin Hood
expressvpn and honey and I thank you all
for joining us on this beautiful
splendid blessed Friday we are truly
blessed being going a Friday together
God you know I saw one time I was at a
store and someone and they'll check out
lady she says to me have a blessed day
on all things I don't believe in God but
I just love that have a blessed day like
damn like good day know blessed that's
pretty nice I was touched like the idea
that God and all of his infinite power
and wisdom was like this day's a blessed
for you for you and only you I love that
not only you we're all blessed to having
fun I just love it so I have a blessed
Friday everyone we got a lot to talk
about we're talking about better help a
lot of controversy there we are talking
about there's been a story that lacroix
popular Sodapop drink which of which I
am a big fan is being sued for putting
cockroach poison and their drinks sounds
a little far-fetched horrible but is it
let's find out we're gonna take a deep
dive we've also got up Kanye West the
great Kanye West had a meeting with
Donald Trump that has got a lot of
people talking and so much more today on
the join me under the gazebo would you
please experience so let's start with
let's start from the top you're better
help okay now better help I think that
there's a lot of misconceptions going
around yeah I'm not we're gonna take a
deep dive know that wasn't going the
whole time was it no no
I'm not used that my laptop is also
right that's right okay all right where
was it you know can you join me into the
better help there's been a lot of
misconception about I'm talking about my
involvement with better hub okay let me
start from the top
better help is an online therapy service
okay which they've sponsored one of our
podcast episodes a couple of months ago
mm-hmm okay now a lot of youtubers have
been getting criticized lately for
having put better help reads on their
videos about mental health about them
being depressed and such and a lot of
people have been accusing them of being
predatory because they're like oh I'm so
depressed and here's better help they're
accusing them of exaggerating their
depression to sell better help or to get
a better help sponsor I don't know and
then people started going through their
Terms of Service and found some
concerning things there as well in the
Terms of Service there was something III
don't remember exactly there was
something like they can't guarantee that
something your conversation private
stuff like that like like you know weird
stuff and so first of all I want to make
clear okay first of all we had one
sponsor with better help that was two
months ago and the topic of mental
health was not brought up in association
with our read at all yeah and to the
best of my recollection I don't think
that we even talked about it in that
episode and it predated our update video
when I talked about being depressed by
month a month at least okay but here's
where I think people got thrown off
because PewDiePie made a new video about
it and he goes through the Terms of
Service and he points out a lot of
questionable things which is fine and he
doesn't like the service and he raises
good points about it
but the way that he presented
my involvement in it I thought was a
little misleading and a little out of
context and it made it look like I was
way more involved with this company than
I was or even that it made it look like
I used my being depressed yeah - somehow
sell better help so I want to show you
guys if I could please exhibit a this is
PewDiePie's video let me go back a
little bit so let's watch this so he
goes on here he's talking about a manor
house I was just joking by the way guys
everyone is a sociopath enter the code
Shan for your cheaper online therapy
today I would never have guessed it will
actually this was the case so this leads
to a lot of the sponsored videos of
these hundred hundred of youtubers being
about mental health which could actually
be a good thing but they are made so
that people sign up for the website
I'm Scott it's Scott for depression to
expression so he's saying there's all
these youtubers that are promoting
better help on videos about depression
he has a problem with that he doesn't
think that that's ethical so here's
here's what he shows here if you're
looking for anything to miss out on
don't miss out on this welcome to
expression whoa I actually messed up
there and completely serious before we
start I have so much respect for each
and every one of you for watching and
being why do you ask for my payment
information now okay as we know I've
been in therapy I've been just dealing
with a lot of stuff that I need to deal
with and I feel good anyways I feel good
that's what is that probably about so
you can access professional affordable
anchor me and counseling I just hit a
wall where it was it was gotten so bad
that it was basically either stop making
videos or disappear also this video is
sponsored by better help more action
about that so the way it's cut makes it
look like my video my update video was
sponsored by better health yeah exactly
and I saw what I felt when I saw it -
yeah and I thought it was I was like
whoa like why would that be there yeah
like that gives totally the wrong
impression
because I've never talked about better
help and depression ever that's when I
did the sponsor read two months ago I
didn't even endorse the product because
I have never used the service we checked
it to make sure we checked it to make
sure that within 24 hours of therapists
contacted us and they did so we did some
due diligence in that regard to test out
the service but I never endorsed it I
never said that I used it to treat my
depression either but it seemed but at
any rate let me let me say focus on this
that seems like the only reasonable
conclusion to make is that he's calling
me out which is I thought I was like
dude what the hell and I was I was
pretty upset with him and I contact him
directly and I was like hey man what why
what's the deal and he says he didn't he
didn't mean to make it look that way and
he made a comment trying to clarify but
people that read the comments compared
to people to watch the video is very
small okay so what happened here is that
Bobby burns this youtuber here made a
video about depression that's sponsored
by better help and he uses my clip in it
talking about depression so here let me
show you this any more videos I just hit
a wall work it was it was gotten so bad
that it was basically either stop making
videos or disappear forever so today's
video is going to be about YouTube
happiness but before we get started make
sure you click that notification bell
lets you know whenever I upload new
videos also this video is sponsored by
though you'll notice that it's from
Bobby's video but he cut out the context
to understand either way cuz the part in
PewDiePie his video yeah let me go back
it's just kind of like a supercut of
examples of people like it doesn't
really inform the butt line so
affordable ank you me and counseling I
just hit a wall I think he did it on my
he didn't do it on purpose but then I
just want to clarify yeah you know
because it makes it to us it did make a
difference
to make a connection between being
depressed and then from that company
yeah we didn't want to do that it's my
personal choice that we made so that it
was kind and so and I think that people
who is the biggest youtuber in the world
talking about those people take it
seriously and it looks like it I mean
that's how I interpreted I could be
wrong I talked to a lot of other people
that saw it that way too and it just
seems like but you can see basically
either so that don't work better help
more information about that at the end
of this video though again and he goes
on to to criticize criticize a lot of
youtubers he also doesn't really
criticize them harshly is more
criticizing the service of better help
names he names a lot of people and he
shows a lot of faces of people and you
know when you're PewDiePie the effect of
that is that yeah he was he was very he
was very tempered in his criticism he
wasn't like coming out no you know he
was being very he was being very
rational and fair about it I mean I'm
not Sarah but again I just want to clear
that up that that video was not in any
way sponsored by better we've only
worked with them once so okay but
regardless of that I think it's pretty
weird that Bobbi used that clip anyway
because I keep seeing that clip going
around of Bobbi using my clip talking
about depression but there's not a clear
separation so people think that I that's
not the case so let me just see here we
go so in response to the criticism so I
first of all I just want to make that
clear okay now in response to dirt I
think that there was some implication
that anyone that works with better help
is negligent a shill or irresponsible or
somehow selling out their fans and even
though I never mentioned depression and
my Reid I do disagree with that
assertion I do personally disagree with
that assertion
now let me talk about this I'm not sure
what first of all I'm not sure what I
could do to vet them more than I did I
mean in a in a perfect world I like the
service it seems interesting and it
seems like would be useful for a lot of
people mm-hmm like on face value seems
like a cool service they're owned by a
publicly traded company and they're one
of the most widely advertised services
on the internet across television radio
podcasting and YouTube so with all the
information available it's a perfectly
rational decision to think that it's a
good useful service and something that's
that's a good good to promote and I mean
again these guys are going through the
Terms of Service and picking it apart
and there's weird questionable stuff in
there but I don't think like this it's a
it's a weird standard to make that you
want the slip the expectation that
anyone you ever work with you're reading
the entire 20 page legal document of the
Terms of Service like I don't think
anyone very few people in the history of
YouTube have ever read the Terms of
Service and I'm willing to bet that if
they did read the Terms of Service they
wouldn't want to work with them because
Terms of Service is written to remove
liability so it always sounds bad
terminal service is meant to sound bad
and scary they're literally the purpose
is to remove liability so to expect
YouTube I don't I think that's a
slippery slope if you are expecting
everyone to read the Terms of Service or
every partner they've ever worked with
them on on face value it's as reputable
as it as a partner as you can have yeah
we've had some offers for responses that
we decline that happens but someone like
better helps like past all the questions
that you would normally ask you know is
they do have good reviews online when we
looked up yeah of course no they and and
look people can promote people decide
how they want to promote different
products I personally wasn't comfortable
promoting it in terms of me being
depressed and I wasn't personally
comfortable saying I've used the service
when I haven't but it seemed good and it
seemed like it'd be useful and helpful
so I promoted it as such now
I think people are just a little too
quick to throw others under the bus and
be way overly cynical about this okay I
understand that it can seem in poor
taste to promote better help in a video
about being depressed which I didn't do
for the record and I have never done but
from the flip side think about it from
their perspective someone like like
boogie Philip DeFranco Bobby burns I
don't know Shane well everyone think of
it from their side instead of being so
cynical and thinking that it's a
celebrity skin
to them it's a win-win it's like oh this
app is gonna help people it seems like a
good service and my videos promoted yeah
it's like you know be optimistic about
it and it feels like a win-win I mean
that's how sponsors Jam YouTube have
always worked like content like sponsors
have video game content you have a video
game sponsorship on it if you make car
content or tech content you have
technology or a car like like content
like sponsors that's how it works so
it's easy to see where people have come
from thinking that it's okay to pair
those up it seems like a win-win and so
I completely understand where they're
coming from and I think once again
people are thinking about it backwards I
think what has been happening is that
better help because there's been this
implication that people have exaggerated
being depressed to sell better help as
that is a very sad way to be really
shitty that would be very shitty and the
people that I've seen being called out
are people that I know have had a
history with mental health issues and so
I think it's kind of ironic to like real
and dogpile on these people you know I
think what I think you guys have it
backwards the people who are being
overly cynical people who have spoken
about mental health issues are the
people that are being approached by
better health right so it's not doesn't
start from wanting to sell better help
it starts from having these issues and
then better help comes in because they
see an opportunity yeah I think that's
how these partnerships have happened and
then finally I've heard this argument
that it's unethical for youtubers to
even make money from promoting service
about mental health that I heard that
it's unethical to take money for that it
should be done for free even and I well
who benefits from doing it for free
better help what you're gonna do free
copy reads we're better out there
business you know the capitalist society
that's the way the world turns I mean
saying it's illogical for youtuber or
immoral for youtuber to collect money to
promote better help is equal is is
similar to saying it is it immoral for a
doctor or a therapist or nurse to get
paid for their work because it benefits
people I mean this is a capitalist
society we this is how at what point
what where does red line at what point
does it become immoral right
there's therapists the charge $50 an
hour $200 an hour $500 an hour at what
point does it become immoral for
therapists to charge 50 large now or
$500 an hour their service not valuable
is that not the capital is is not a
commodity I mean you know what I'm
saying if they're better at it do they
not deserve to get paid more so this
blanket statement that it's somehow
immoral to sponsor online therapy
strikes me as an odd one and not one
that makes much sense especially could
sitting here in the United States our
hospitals our doctors everything cancer
treatment for chrissake is heavily
monetized yeah and I personally find
that to be disgraceful but are we saying
that they shouldn't get paid at all they
should they volunteer I mean it's a it's
an argument that doesn't make much sense
to me and it falls apart in my mind when
you
to break it down it's a nice it's a nice
stop but it doesn't really make that
much sense now once again I want to
acknowledge this is somebody I worked
with one time months ago and I never
promoted them in context of being
depressed and I never said that I used
their service to treat my depression I'm
not a doctor I'm not journalists I'm not
a lawyer this is my opinion feel free to
disagree but I've been watching this
kind of devolve and I think that people
are being way overly cynical about this
and it's just another example of like I
don't know it just feels like one of
these things that just making YouTube
even more toxic mm-hmm
like even more distrustful of people and
even more cynical of each other and the
people and I just don't know why and and
I I don't know I just didn't feel it
just doesn't feel right this whole thing
and sure some people are being
opportunistic probably some but that's
always gonna happen yeah I don't know
someone now there's there's been a lot
of controversy about Philip DeFranco
because he was apparently sponsored with
them and dunno I don't know anything
about what Philip defranco's up to not
commenting at all about that and I know
like he had been connected somehow with
Shane's better help sponsorship he's not
connected to us at all ours came through
an agency and let me say this by the way
when you work with sponsors we work with
a lot of sponsors here on the podcast
they come through agencies that vet them
I check for their credibility to collect
payments and make sure they're legit
okay because obviously yeah so obviously
we as business owners and as
entertainers are not going to read the
Terms of Service of all of our partners
that's insane nobody has time for that
so we entrust our agency to to verify
the legitimacy of these companies and I
don't think they failed in this case I
mean we think about it too I don't just
pass the buck completely them I make a
conscious decision to work with someone
or not but in this case I don't regret I
I mean like yeah there's some
questionable things in terms of service
but let me say this with the information
I had at the time I made the right
decision
and and and that's it you know I think
if you want to criticize the company
that's one thing and that's totally fine
but yeah to come at youtubers who have
worked with them seems overly cynical
and toxic and it's just not now I don't
know she's not necessary I don't know
and you guys another crutch of this
argument is the implication that people
don't there's so many sponsors available
on YouTube now you don't have to act the
press to get a sponsor on YouTube mm-hmm
you really don't I mean I don't know it
just it make it I don't know if that
whole thing just made me feel really sad
I felt really bad honestly when I saw
Felix's video and kind of the way it was
portrayed I'm not gonna lie I felt it
felt really awful and I know we didn't
mean to do it
but like I didn't want people to think I
know a lot of people were getting the
wrong and I felt bad for all the other
people he named to because it's like
these are people that already have been
dealing with stuff and it's like it's
like man I don't know just overly
cynical and again I chose not to talk
about my depression people make
decisions I didn't want to do that but
that's just my opinion you can feel free
to disagree with me and that's fine okay
we can have dissenting opinions you
don't have to come [ __ ] murder my
family and [ __ ] down my throat
because I happen to have my own opinion
about this I think YouTube's gotten way
too [ __ ] toxic way too overly cynical
and when you start throwing good honest
youtubers under the bus that I think
they're I think we need to reel it back
a little bit you know there's some it's
like I'm not saying that people
shouldn't be criticized mm-hmm but it's
like I don't know just
just felt bad the whole thing felt bad
so that's that's that's my take and I
hope that you won't come to my house
after am attempt to murder me
over is dissenting opinion because it's
not that serious after all and if you
and if you are thinking that you may
consider it coming on over matter help
calm / 83 talking to their therapist
[Laughter]
okay I think I handled that okay I
didn't get too upset right no I know I'm
not trying to throw shade at anyone I'm
not trying to be controversial I'm not
trying to stir the pot I'm tired of
feeling like everyone is out to get
everyone look and it might feel ironic
coming from now okay let me acknowledge
that I know somebody who said who's
notorious for you know making fun of
people online yeah but hey that's just
my [ __ ] opinion okay on this topic
specifically all right also well
whatever I think I put that that that
the rest
we've got Lacroix you guys have all
heard we're almost to a break but let me
set this up and then we'll go to a break
Lucroy the Saudi pop of choice crack
open a fresh one Cheers now a lot of you
probably heard this headline that
Lacroix is being sued for putting
unnatural chemicals in its drink yes zip
it up EULA limonene how do you say that
limo 9 limo Nene limo Nene it's a
chemical that is also inside cockroach
insecticide now this is a heavy rose
that has been widely seen around social
media your car crash
people have been texting me Chris D'Elia
texted me he's like dude what the [ __ ]
because we're both a little crow boy I
don't even drink water anymore my look
but seriously not a joke don't drink
water you [ __ ] that peasant juice waters
called present use now this is cockerel
well is it you know when the Lacroix
came out it was a high it was a
top-shelf beverage I remember it was
really expensive but now they saw like
what happened it's all on sale all the
time always it's like three bucks for a
12 pack or something yeah dude [ __ ]
brutal man they're competing with water
you believe that so anyway listen to me
it sounded far-fetched yeah so I wanted
to take a deep dive
what's that steak who are the players
who benefits the most from this and is
it true the Conqueror the lich the
Lacroix controversy Lacroix gate stay
tuned after this break we will dive
right into that here on the h3 podcast
gazebo experience join me under the
gazebo won't you please Robin Hood is an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks ETFs options and cryptos here's
the catch my dudes and this what's makes
it Robin Hood no Commission that's right
zero many of these training apps are
going to charge you dollars per trade
Robin Hood Kobe is Robin the hood for
the hood you feel me they strive to make
financial services work for everyone and
not just the wealthy Dan uses this app
he loves it he swears by it
I don't trade I don't know anything
about trading but from what he says it's
simple to use it has built-in
explanations and it's a great place to
learn how to trade that stuff's
complicated I'm intimidated but Robin
Hood seems to make it easy intuitive fun
learning experience and again no
Commission on those trades folks it's
easy as that Robin Hood platform lets
you view stock collections you can view
most popular and sectors as
entertainment social media can curated
categories like female CEOs I'm
investing in those across the board I'm
already invested in one and analyst
ratings up by hotel for every stock
learn by doing you're going to learn how
to
fest and build your portfolio on
Robinhood they've got all the tools all
the trades making all the moves it's
everybody's invested in stock I'm I'm
the odd man out
I'm back here the other day with like
all of our employees were here from
Teddy fresh and h3 and everybody's
dabbling in stock
I was like yeah I've got to get on that
Robin Hood is the place to do it
now here's what's awesome Robin Hood is
giving our listeners a furries out tore
it down even giving our listeners a free
stock like Apple 4 or sprint to help you
build your portfolio for for signups go
to h3 podcasts dot ravine hood calm and
get a random free stock dial is freaking
cool so head on over to issue a podcast
on Robin Hood calm and start trading to
day my dudes listen with all the recent
news about online security breaches it's
hard not to worry about where my data
goes everybody's leaking my data my
passwords my credit cards my social
security number
it's everywhere and guess what I don't
need it leaking anymore
making all I purchase or simply email
put your private information at risk try
accessing a non secured network maybe at
the airport boom guess who's got your
credit card information [ __ ] some
random dude in India you want that guy
having it no okay now here's the deal
that's why I decided to take back my
privacy and start using it's the first
weird first VPN as easy as apps that run
seamlessly in the background of my
computer phone or tablet turn on
expressvpn it protection only takes one
click access VPN secures and anonymizes
your internet browser by crippling your
data and hiding your public IP address
protect yourself with expressvpn it
costs less than seven dollars a month
I'll tell you what cost more than seven
dollars a month trying to get back your
stolen identity you got duck to Lord
you're gonna talk to government agencies
gonna take a lot more time to money that
seven dollars a month to get your effing
credit card information back your social
security number fixed seven dollars a
month is a is a walk in the park
protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get three months
free and expressvpn dot-com / a tree
that's exp ress VPN cough / h 3 4 3
months free with a one-year package
visit expressvpn dot-com / HP to learn
more and keep your credit card hands out
of weird Indian dudes do want to steal
your credit card not that only Indians
would but that's just in my mind I
imagine that's where they are my
opinions are not endorsed by expressvpn
[Laughter]
imagine your old coupon clipping grandpa
you can shrink down and put it in your
computer and use as a plugin on your
browser all the time that's what honey
is when you think honey think grandpa
clipping coupons all the time for you on
the Internet
here's what honey does you install it
it's a plugin when you shop online
pretty much everywhere I'm talking
Amazon I'm talking Evie I'm talking
Walmart Macy's dominoes dominoes you can
get Pizza coupons they are scanning the
web for the most active up-to-date best
coupons available so that when you're at
checkout
honey's like I got you dog or well your
grandpa wouldn't say that what would
your grandpa say sorry I got a coupon
for that study
that's what honey says I got a coupon
for that Sonny
that's what honey says and they come at
the last minute at checkout like the
Americans arriving World War two boom
last minute coupon on the desk look at
this
we once bought Jack some blankets I
saved literally $360 from Macy's Oh
what that's what honey does boom I got
you Sonny that's what your grandpa says
is he's coupon clipping coupons all
night by the fireplace
that's what honey does for you I'm
telling you try it out it's free it's a
risk free it's just a Chrome extension
it takes just two clicks to install give
it a shot for a week and see if you
don't love it apparently what did they
say that it saved our it saved our our
audience hundreds of thousands of
dollars who have already used this Lake
it's got five stars a hundred thousand
five star reviews and ten million
members are you freaking kidding me
never overpay again with honey so let
them know who sent you go to get a go to
join honey calm slash h3 that's join
honey dot-com slash h3
welcome back my little gazebos before we
get into is Lacroix poison I want to say
new h3h3 video out which was a lot of
fun honestly yeah I have got to say I
really what this one I took my time and
I enjoyed the process I took all the
time I needed we worked on it for like
two weeks and I would just sit down and
edit and enjoy the experience and the
sketch and everything so I think that I
really enjoyed and the reception was
amazing I mean everyone was really happy
about it I gotta say I didn't think I
don't think I saw one complaint actually
have a collection of them for you if you
want me to read this on but you know I'm
just no complaint
it felt good I think me and HeLa
realized I think recently we call our
friends gauzy boys the gazebos I like
that are you a gazebo z-boys maybe we
should name our child gazebo that's a
good luck gender-neutral name gazebo I
should give birth under a gazebo you
know how people have all this weird like
water pool yeah a gazebo birth birth
it's beautiful thank you I feel like
I've seen some people echoing the
sediment that I I have spoken a lot of
times that I don't want to be making
videos like that but I feel like
recently me I have always wanted to go
back to making videos like that mm-hmm
and just until recently like we weren't
there mentally yeah yeah that's what I
mean that's what it was really yeah it's
just that I I literally couldn't I don't
know what it was but recently we really
felt like we wanted to try and go back
to making like high quality in fact they
can't break for like we didn't make
videos for like three months it kind of
started to crave the feeling of like
being creative and
something yeah that's what it was born
from that we really wanted to say okay
let's make the vet the best video we can
not cut any corners there's no deadline
mm-hmm and so that's what we did and and
it was fun it was great I loved
everything yeah
so hopefully more to come
so anyway I'm glad you guys enjoyed
thanks for all the wonderful comments
and support tomorrow and Los Angeles for
all of our la-based gazebos where what
what time is it now you're surprising
well you can just google rip and it
right Oh Thor but what time is it at
11:00 hold all right well ela does that
check out this new teddy fresh what do
you call this tracksuit warmer
it's a tracksuit tracksuit that's coming
out this winter look at this fresh [ __ ]
the fit is insane the comfort level is
spicy hot it's breathable dude this
thing is insane this is so comfortable I
mean it was my goal for a long time to
make a trex Teddy fresh watch out watch
out haters because Teddy fresh is coming
hard so it's at 11:00 a.m. tomorrow
tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. at rip and dip
stores next to the supreme store and is
it Hollywood and Fairfax Avenue Fairfax
so we'll be there for about an hour yeah
or two I know got the new rippin dip
collection collab coming out very
excited about so see you guys there and
let's do it is Lacroix poison that is
the question we are looking to resolve
today who are the players at work who
benefits from this before we get into
this Lacroix boy under the gazebo a
story and I'd like to say cheers to
everybody and the boys and back to enjoy
everyone crack open your Lacroix and
have a nice refreshing sip of all
natural essence soda pop
so a new lawsuit alleges that Lacroix is
not all-natural and the chemical
limonene in Lacroix is also in cockroach
insecticide now one thing that I thought
first of all when I heard that is just
because it's toxic to cockroaches
doesn't necessarily mean anything you
hear [ __ ] like that all the time like
our neighbors have vet
he says chewing gum artificial
sweetening chewing gum is deadly
poisonous to dogs yeah just because it's
toxic to cockroach doesn't like that
seems like an effort to scare like if
it's dangerous to humans say that mm-hmm
it's dangerous the cockroach cockroaches
are gross and I have a gross mental
image of cockroaches but it doesn't
necessarily mean anything besides that
so that seems kind of manipulative
Hedlund so at first some thing what's
going on here you know is this really
about the ingredients or something else
at play mm-hmm so let's actually break
down these claims from the lawsuit who
are making these claims all right let's
start with the chemical li mo Nene am I
saying that right or might just sound
like ooh yeah how could I it cannot be
called Li mo Nene then somebody's
Christ's sake help me I'll check li mo
Nene I'm 1 9 o ly mo 9 that's gotta be
it that sounds way more intelligent I'm
not American I'm so bad at
pronounciating things it's like
ridiculous Alaimo 9 I think it's Lyme o
9 damn you killed it you just read it
like someone from outside of the US
well I'm sorry you know my brain is
[ __ ] up so pubchem the National
Institutes of Health open database for
chemical compounds explicitly calls lime
o 9 a naturally occurring chemical and a
major component of oil extraction from
citrus peels so sounds pretty natural
right as the name suggests
Lamoni n-- is commonly used to give food
or other products a lemony flavor and
fragrance so it is a naturally occurring
compound that comes off of lemons so
limonene lime Oh need them
crushed your [ __ ] Spelling Bee champ
so how about the claims that it causes
kidney toxicity and cancer while the
same company pubchem also states there
is inadequate evidence in humans for the
carcinogenic properties of Lamoni n--
there are some evidence of male rats
experiencing problems including tumors
as a consequence of Lamoni exposure but
none of those findings have been
properly reproduced in humans meanwhile
more recent studies suggest that Lamoni
n-- is actually anti-cancer what it's
lemon I mean it's a naturally-occurring
lemon now how did this company come to
claim that it's even unnatural because I
was reading that the FDA because
everything that FDA does is so nebulous
and undefined defines for whatever
reason Lamoni n-- as an artificial
flavor mmm-hmm but according to this
magazine and I don't know what the
reason is for that is it a naturally
occurring chemical that comes from lemon
okay now the other chemical that's being
accused of being toxic is the lena liu i
why can i not you know Lou it's about Li
Na lol that's a goofy S word lena Lou as
another additive used as a flavoring
agent it's naturally occurring found
within many types of flowers spice
plants including the nice yeah it
includes mint scented herbs laurels and
cinnamon it is most definitely used an
insecticide as well that part is true
but that doesn't mean it's poisonous to
humans after all as I pointed out dogs
can't eat chocolate yet I eat 20 bars a
day explain that you can't
the only real toxic effects of lino Lou
has been documented to inflict on humans
is mild skin and eye irritation namely
from air saw from air forms of the
chemical being squirted in your eyes for
take a lemon squirt it in your eyes oh
I'm gonna sue the lemon people no that's
not how it works folks also
coincidentally research suggests that it
may be an anti-cancer ingredient that
leaves only Lionel prop property
Lionel propionate prop problem unit
propionate what back in fifth grade
trying to read again read to the class
Ethan can you read it look around the
class and say oh my god I can see it
after these words that leaves
Lionel propionate derived from plants
like ginger and lavender and another
common flavoring and fragrance added has
been shown to help inhibit the
proliferation of prostate cancer I'm
going to shove those right above my ass
at least in the form of Nagas me
kumquats
[Music]
so there you go so unless Lacroix is
secretly including 50% of the beverage
as Lionel then drinkers don't have
anything to fear because it's not even
anywhere close to being harmful these
are all naturally occurring flavors and
by the way these are all flavors that
many companies use and many of their
products to flavor their beverages I
mean it makes it act like Lacroix is out
there just pouring yeah [ __ ] crows
insecticide for no reason they're like
I'm gonna save 50 cents and pour some
poisonous no this is a widely used
flavoring agent that seems by all count
to be natural after all so what's going
on here what is going on what is going
on let me say this even water is toxic
when you consume too much you can
actually get water poisoning okay not
some incredible suit of water I'm suing
big water now as somebody who's been on
the receiving
and of bogus lawsuits this place this
lawsuit stinks to high hat okay now my
theory big soda is behind it and I that
might sound like a joke but think about
it the company Lacroix dominates
dominates the market if you go to any
grocery store any convenience store gets
what's on the shelf and guess what
people want Lacroix every time Lacroix
ela please let's not get into that now
that's a whole nother heated debate look
they got a great marketing I don't know
what I don't know how but they dominate
like I've I mean I've slammed Lacroix
previously I'm apart guys look like
these [ __ ] act like they
invented soda water but here I am
drinking it every episode so what's
going on now at the same time as Lacroix
is killing it and I'm talking about
eight hundred and twenty seven million
dollars in sales last year
guess what's simultaneously declining
hugely in sales soda bombs sugary drinks
as people realize that consuming 50
grams of sugar is poison and not Lionel
or whatever how about 50 grams of sugar
can we sue coca-cola
for giving me diabetes I'd like to maybe
I will
so here we have Lacroix dominating the
market big soda falling down what's
happening now the these big boys are
losing market share to Lacroix and their
soda water brands are are getting
smashed they're dominating the market
and these big soda companies they they
need to get in because their business is
suffering so to me from the outside it
seems like a total hit job of
misinformation and the lawsuit is gonna
get thrown out you can trust me on that
but the damage has already been done
their friend because you hear it on the
news I see it on social media I see it
everywhere you really once and it's
stuck in your head I know and I know
it's [ __ ] up is that nobody goes
nobody goes oh that
weird and that doesn't make that much
sense they say they go what there's
poison in Lacroix we're all [ __ ] gonna
die we drink Lacroix and they have
successfully tarnish the reputation of
this pristine beautifully branded and
naturally flavored soda pop and and
that's it that's the beauty of this
lawsuit it's totally bogus it's gonna
get thrown out and they have tarnished
the reputation and everybody's been
taking the bait and meanwhile mr.
coca-cola has got his feet up and he's
drinking a look Roy because he knows
it's a superior beverage but meanwhile
he's peddling his [ __ ] nasty
coca-cola [ __ ] so I say to all of
our listeners all the gazebos out there
crack open a little Croix have a sip
enjoy yourself and know that you are
enjoying an all-natural sugar-free
beverage and you are you are Lacroix boy
your gazebo boy you are my boy so have a
sip and enjoy cheers everybody Cheers
ela you really that's all loud set music
I tried on purpose mm-hmm so that's it
nice to the bunked two big topics
there's 60 minutes this is 60 minutes
gone gate I was working on my Alex Jones
impression I thought was pretty good I
did it during love like the copy reads
but we caught it but I kind of want to
do it now Kanye Kanye gave Trump make
America great hat during his White House
visit it really hurts my throat it's
pretty good
I need to figure out how to do it where
it doesn't irritate my throat yeah Kanye
gave Trump a make America great hat
during the White House visit purple hat
you guys heard about all this Kanye
West's madness okay so let's talk about
Kanye West no yeah so Kanye met Trump
and we're gonna talk about that but
before we do in our intern who's a super
fan of Kanye West as you all know had
some suggestions
for Kanye West in our last week in our
previous episode he had suggested that
he make the Hat purple which would
symbolize the joining of the Democrats
and the Republicans
exactly red and blue makes purple tears
here is Kanye in a purple hat not
evident to much honestly we had thought
that it said make America great you
can't really read it it doesn't say that
though not interesting what does it say
showing up in a purple hat
it says exposed world says Ian because
he knows those world no but um what he
did and then his other suggestion
hearing suggestion was don't wear hat
that says make America great again wear
hat that says make America great yeah
and what happens later on that day my
friends well I can't open it's behind
that picture it is you know make America
great this is I'm telling now people
have suspected that Kanye lurks the the
reddit of Kanye on reddit and the clip
the highlight of Ian talking about it
was on that subreddit so there is a
chance I swear to you now that Kanye
West saw Ian suggestion and if he comes
out with the purple make America great
hat which is a great idea and I hope he
does the world oh my god that is gonna
be amazing
how do you how did you feel in seeing
this I saw you you seem pretty excited
do you think that he saw your
presentation I'm gonna tell myself that
yeah mm-hmm I hope you did do you think
there's a chance though or do you think
I mean like I'm not gonna fully commit
cuz it's not purple if it was purple ago
he 90 percent yeah but well based on a
percentage out of a hundred what did the
chances you think you saw that your
presentation the clip got a lot of views
that was six days ago before he did that
it's interesting timing yeah and this
spread looks like a shitty one not like
the design one he pooped it out real
fast yeah you could just buy a red hat
and do embroidery and give me a
percentage wow that's got to make you
feel amazing oh yeah he better send me a
hat that's the least he could do [ __ ] us
up Wow
I hope he takes would you wear it in if
it was purple and said make America
great what if it wasn't
what if it's red he's like no I won't
wear I don't know kind of heat of the
street I wouldn't wear it if it was red
know if it was purple I feel like I kind
of have to yeah you do you what [ __ ] you
can yeah I love that you wouldn't worry
you wouldn't wear it well anyway so
there's that and so we all congratulate
in he's really growing up we're all very
proud of him we're all very proud of an
intern he's really flourished
he's burped he's turned it to Kanye's
personal advisor he's really just coming
to his own so I wanted to thank you to
end the intern he's great and when we
first saw that purple hat there was that
moment where we thought that was it yeah
that was 50% though down I mean that's
nothing to be scoff yeah no I mean I
think he's probably right I mean from
what I understand yeah he legitimately
is like he's a lurker he's on the
culling a fan for how many points did it
have on the reddit uh Ian well I wasn't
on the read it was on the Kanye fan site
oh man forum and how was it will
received people were on board
I remember acting everyone to [ __ ] on me
yeah don't be scared
interesting yeah well he got maybe not
him personally but you know I bet some
of his handlers probably do check out
you know all right let's just let's go
with that Wow that's it that's really
exciting
well did you out your username then if
you posted or one time when I was posted
yeah he's still clearly right now you're
lurking under condom
you didn't post it did you in he's
denying [ __ ] it was definitely y'all
know is account out
but anyway so Kanye met with Trump and
there's a lot of blowback as you can
expect but I'm here to focus on the
funny the whimsical the comedic there's
one great moment you can see Kanye's
password on his phone I came and I was
like Ian what's funniest password and
he's like just zeros as I come in he's
like five you said five him but I guess
he's revise his this whole thing going
on one of his legendary I airplane the I
airplane we have a picture that but
Trump very interesting Kanye's just
going off for like 20 minutes and
dominating the conversation and I find
it just so interesting that how do I get
that angle back this angle here he
doesn't really look at Trump when he's
talking and Trump's face is just sitting
there kind of embracing I got this
angles all isn't the one I wanted for
Christ's sake what else pick it up Kanye
is a smart as Tesla and Freud began can
decode this but put that a fleece in the
Indiana and he he looked at my friend
he's below freezing mark I'm gonna go
ahead drop some bombs for the 98
percentile IQ test I have a 75
percentile of all human beings but it
was counting eight numbers backwards
authors ravine so we're going to work on
that one
the other ones nine
Tesla Freud you know so that I guess
he's trying to say he's very intelligent
am I correct in that and he's definitely
coming across that way in your not
commenting
I think he's parsing his words but he's
got the whole forum listening on
everybody things got so complicated for
Union you know what I'm saying like you
can't just take talk his opinion anymore
he's a leader he's a thought leader on
anybody's PR the influencer I know he
needs a PR I know can't have the he's
got a reputation now he doesn't have
some [ __ ] username he's face they
know who he is he has a reputation if he
says the wrong thing this go all the
mobs coming yeah this was beyond
username this is real [ __ ] well Ian can
you at least confirm he's trying to say
that he is intelligent yeah that's the
general idea yeah I mean Nate's once
again like the power point where I
showed all the people he can compare
them smell surprises yeah and Tesla
wasn't in there and and who was the the
Disney character oh that's vanellope von
schweetz yeah von schweetz
he should have said I'm like work on it
he's doing the math anyway boy you know
so you know said that his moment you
know I'm saying like but anyway so that
was so that was interesting and then
there was the one I guess the one that
really pissed people off was that he
hugged Trump at the end we saw this
don't are there's more oh God he showed
him a picture that what is this even in
hell yeah
and decode it's not his design he took
it from someone who did it as their
University thesis hmm a few years ago
and the guy they asked him they were
like what do you think about this he's
like I think it's kind of cool that
Kanye saw it no idea how and so what are
the chances we're gonna get this
airforce one made in zero percent okay
all right hater the forums gonna eat you
alive for that one so bring back that
picture you love them all wearing hats
yeah kanya gave them I want to see I
want to see Jared Kushner he looks like
such a dweeb you can see the whole
family here and one says maker it's a
great thing and make earth great again
earth is like don't talk for me yeah I
know Jared cracks yeah great again and
travel space again make earth great
again what does that mean one was earth
earth used to be [ __ ] dealt when the
dinosaurs were around NASA Chris played
out earth displayed and cared look so
uncomfortable in that hat man but
they're making a work they're rocking it
they're making a work what's the blue
ones day that's the earth that's good
and the black one says trouble space
again so all right you can you can get
that off so then we've got to hug the
notorious hug which apparently now I was
like in what would it cuz they're the
backlash has been so severe and I've
read some things like Ti the famous
rapper what he wrote I was like damn
that is [ __ ] harsh and their friends
I'm not read it for you guys but I was
like in what what exactly did he say
that that upset people so much and what
in well in you want to say what you told
me or is that too controversial just
that he didn't say anything new was kind
of the same answer
it's the same Kanye from the last six
months
mmm but I guess what happened is he
showed a lot of love and he hugged Trump
and that's what some people up so no
real medium so here it is well then I
like and I guess they like me and we're
gonna have lunch we're gonna talk I did
the Secret Service not tackle his ass
right now I love this guy I got you it
was all the ploy just some I said a long
con there was like a plot to a movie
like that like where he tries to get
close to the king some kung fu hero yeah
that movie sack yep good one dude what
it make sense if Kanye was like the star
of his own hero and he just stabbed
Trump I mean that'd be a wild twit
everyone's like whoa and gave him some
love and in fact I probably ruined the
moment for you guys to let me go back I
have a bad habit of pausing and talking
a lot and Sheila was trying to correct
me yeah but it was too late I already
paused it so here we go again
everyone to enjoy people that I like and
I guess they like me and we're gonna
have lunch we're gonna talk I'm sorry I
got a fuzzy look at all these people
there's so many people packing the room
so many press it's actually really
annoying you can't even hear what
they're saying
yes cameras they make pictures do you
need what the [ __ ] does she know about
cameras what yeah okay I'm not gonna
pause it anymore
that's but I love this guy right here
let me get this guy
I love this guy right here yeah that's
my heart I didn't want to put you in
episode there you go now that was that
okay now let me read TI's response it's
a flavour there was the reaction this
this was cold-blooded man this this you
know what happened he got go sir or did
I was trying to he got go started by Ti
Ian do you agree this was a go starting
so let me read this [ __ ] now I've been
extremely patient and made it a point to
not jump to any premature conclusions
about Yee and his antics partially due
to lessons learned from the outcome of
other similar situations dealing with my
brother Wayne which I merely mishandled
a bit in hindsight but now this [ __ ] is
next-level futuristic [ __ ] hoppin Bob
Stephen off Django ass [ __ ] what does
that mean in those are all references to
is sort of like the Uncle Tom thing what
a [ __ ] that was a was a book that had
like very racist imagery I believe I'm
not exactly sure but then he refers to
Django which obviously that was a
Tarantino movie sure okay literary
references very highbrow do you know
from what I can gather this is the most
repulsive disgraceful embarrassing act
of desperation and auctioning off of one
soul to gain power I've ever seen
now I recall you asking me to come with
you to have this meeting and I decline
naturally but bro if ain't time I would
have been in there with you and you
behave that spineless Lee in my presence
I feel like I'd be compelled to slap the
[ __ ] out of you bro for the people you
asked kissing and boot licking on a
whole new level and I refuse to
associate myself with something so vile
weak and inconsiderate to the effect
this has on the greater good of all of
our people I'm a true believer in it
ain't what you do it's how you do it and
this [ __ ] is regurgitating at one time
it was a pleasure to work alongside you
now I'm ashamed to have been associated
with you to all the people who follow ye
you use the
yay oh [ __ ] yay right
yes Kanye yes I'm not part of a forum or
anything
yay so we will follow ya musically
socially or even personally who are
confused heartbroken and fury ated let
me make this clear this [ __ ] ain't cool
this is own cups this is a movie made
yeah this is a movie a made for yay this
is a play to put him in position he'd
like to see himself in we are not on his
mind as he makes these comments and
decisions don't follow this puppet we're
we're off caps now because as long as
I've lived I've learned that it benefits
a man nothing at all
to gain the world if to do so he must
lose his soul we just saw a mr. West's
soul on auction if you listen closely
you can hear the tears of our ancestors
hit the floor the amps all I can say is
I've reached my limit
this is my stop I'm officially done
middle finger Trump and his little
cookie boy Wow
that's cold-blooded [ __ ] how did how did
you how did that make you feel again I
mean I I can't fully weigh in on what
that imagery feels like or to see that
if you're you know african-american in
this country I don't know so yeah it's a
reaction I I completely understand it I
see why he would have that and you know
I respect his opinion they're very
political 1ti a dude from what I
understand was like his most ardent
defender up to this point is that true
en diamond is working on campaigning
it's a tough situation I only met that's
got it as if I'm calling that's got
alright yeah that's good I when I read
it it's hard to disagree with the stuff
that he's saying it's like I don't know
like we said last time kinda like you
can see what kinda was trying to do but
in it's not a pure heart movement it's
more polite political than it should be
I guess it's it's just so
polarizing it's like on one hand I see
where he's coming from and on the other
hand I see the black community as seeing
Donald Trump as a a symbol of oppression
of establishment or whatever you know
but I also see like I don't know I see
it from both sides I don't really think
he's going to try and run for president
- I don't see so [ __ ] cringy bro
please no no not support Ian do you vote
for Kanye's bro I would never vote for
because I like it doesn't that kind of
ruin everything
what so if he's is that love as
president yes wait is he just trying to
get political what is this is he trying
to be genuine and spread love and like
bridge the divide or so you just want to
run for president positioning himself
because that's what the I was saying and
all right yeah and the conversation was
very like about Kanye like he was
talking about easy and indeed us and how
now so strange yeah yeah and it's kind
of like well look Kanye watching his
rant strikes me very much as somebody
who is having a manic episode he's been
diagnosed as bipolar and when I see him
talking there he strikes me as someone
that's not fully grounded mm-hmm you
know what I'm saying
and so I take that into consideration -
yeah and Mike he's feeling strong more
than usual emotions because he's in this
manic state and so he's like I love
Trump I love what he represents as
someone who did something that was
impossible I love what if the idea of
what he's trying to do of like bringing
jobs back to America in America first
right Kanye sees that as he just sees
the best in it he sees the positive
message and he doesn't and there's a lot
of people that criticize that movement
but he just he's full with like strong
emotions and love and this manic state
and he'll and and so that's he's not
he's not being smart he's being
emotional mm-hmm and so it's like he
Howard Lee says that it
the S&L speech he straight-up says like
we need to stop thinking with our minds
and start thinking with our hearts so I
think he's just he's not no I don't
think he's grounded right home and
apparently in our while we were noticing
earlier he talked about how he was
misdiagnosed as bipolar and he was just
sleep-deprived and so he's off his
medicine and I'm washing the son be like
dude you must be really sleep-deprived
right now that's the case so I don't
know the whole thing is just wild and
weird is he gonna run as a Republican
cuz that's kind of what he's a meal in
itself is that yeah we're independent
he might just try and do his own thing
or a circus that would be a real circus
maybe he wants VP Trump Kanye won't that
be a wild world so that is Kanye decoded
here on 60 minutes there you go welcome
hit me with that sixty minutes tonight
under the gazebo
Lucroy is it poisonous I say [ __ ] no get
that [ __ ] on sale little cookie boy aka
Kanye West oh I can't say that is that
racist I don't know wait he did throw
that in while listing off like Zombo and
all those other things I've never heard
of that one either I didn't know that
was a racist thing so hit me with that
sixty minutes is Kanye West
Trump's little cookie boy find out today
under the gazebo and better help is it a
scam some say yes some say no
cockroaches I like that dunno me or
whatever yeah I love the non-committal
oh is here I hear the craziest clickbait
on the news they go the there's an
outbreak of the
blue should you be concerned let's find
out
feel like universally when they say that
it just it means me no no yeah imagine
if the answer is yes yes you should not
leave your house
Ebola is back the Black Plague is
rampant yes be concerned yeah what else
we got man everyone having fun on this
Friday
find out more tonight
is Kanye Trump's little cookie boy yes
the answer is we should watch this
pro-life lady oh yeah got a lot of stuff
but you those got has suggestions so
let's watch it you guys may have seen
this great little one lowlife lady man
roundhouse kicks pro-life woman this
shit's crazy man love this this is why
we're here my dudes 5 million wow this
one look at his outfit first of all yeah
he's got boots for kickin that's just
what he'll do yeah no spoilers
imagine kicking somebody just imagine
kicking somebody like how [ __ ]
unstable do you have to be to throw kick
anyway yeah who can't like if you're not
enough UFC fighting ring there's no like
throwing a kick like who are you Bruce
Lee
[Applause]
what
Hey destruction of private property
tastes a lot he gets raped by somebody
and they're like hi 16 year old I can
have it that's really compelling I am
pro-choice by the way for I'm I'm
strongly in favor of pro-choice I mean
I'm just gonna say that for the record
okay and if you think that makes me a
[ __ ] or whatever that's fine because we
can have a difference in opinion I
respect that you are pro-life how about
that
you [ __ ] haters you can have an
opinion and I can have a different
opinion you want to come to my dress and
kill me because I'm pro-choice suck my
tiny Jewish dick but this guy's a
[ __ ] idiot so it's fun to watch no I
did the perfect I just wanted to say
like people who are a pro-life I
understand their point because it comes
from a religious place
yeah and they think the you're murdering
a baby I personally disagree I don't
think you're murdering a baby but if you
did think that then I can understand how
are you be why you again why would you
be so passionate about it so it's like
it's just like unsolvable yeah it's like
killing baby it's like I can't think of
two more opposites killing a baby worst
thing ever not killing a baby
you know I don't think it's going baby
this guy certainly doesn't you gotta go
back a little cuz I think this guy
should have been aborted
I love that I meant to kick your phone
ok who does that
imagine kicking someone's phone it's
still assault it's like he doesn't
really apologized either he's just like
I [ __ ] up I kicked you in the face
look at that tongue out yeah it's like
an anime move it probably runs with his
arms back there we go he rounds up baby
here we go that's basically a warning
shot you know you heard World War 2 now
on you know World War 2 and Israel does
it over like Gaza they'll drop leaflets
and say hey we're about to bomb this
place you better get out hmm
that's what he's doing dropping leaflets
on hey see that you clear the area
because a bomb is about to drop that's
like a crazy kick I doubt that guy will
too much power to be praying look can we
slow motion up here let's go to 0.25 on
this break it down speed 0.25 let's
enjoy okay mmm oh we got sound all right
it's thinking about it
I love how like the conversation is over
and now a power failure like he probably
doesn't have a lot of muscle mass but he
ends up well affirmed kick right there
yeah sounds of hell there you go
everyone enjoyed that that was a
favorite of the week
Shane continues his documentary about
Jake Paul I don't have that much to say
about any of his new series except for
this this was my favorite detail that
came out of the new episode it's a small
little detail but I thought it was great
I'll share for you guys now my dad's
good old Greg Paul it's it's actually
like an RV though I'm gonna give you a
quick tour the boss give you an update
it's like you can like yeah there's like
a there's like a bed in there and like
he like drives around and like he sleeps
in there my dad Jake sounds fun his dad
is lived at the Tim penthouse for months
sleeping in a school van outside that's
now a guy who's been accused of having
sex with underage girls and kissing
underage girls on camera should not be
sleeping in a school outside a house
with a bunch of young kids all right
Greg Paul get your [ __ ] [ __ ] together
get your life together and get the
[ __ ] move out of the school bus for
Christ's sake Greg what the hell is
wrong with you God as a weird yeah
that's the weirdest goddamn [ __ ] ever so
in red palm [ __ ] me your life together
man god that's it that's my own that's
my take away Banksy shreds is art and
whatever some [ __ ] should I talk
about this Banksy shreds his art it's
kind of cool except it was kind of also
lame I'm not being honest because well
here let's watch it so Banksy sold a
piece of art or no he didn't sell I
don't know how it came to be in the
print of his art so he sold it
originally and then it was recently I
don't know the story yeah I believe
original yeah and being auctioned I
think the story goes that he built the
shredder into it like ten years ago with
the intention that it if it ever went on
auction he would do this so this is like
a long con but what I'm wondering is
he's so anti like capitalist he
originally sold the art to somebody
right like how did the auction house get
it yeah yeah that's a very good question
okay so I don't really understand
okay so it's not really is it a
statement I don't I'm not sure what was
the statement I think it's funny just a
gag it's like I gotcha
okay it's like oh it's like an actual
cool prank I thought he was like an
anti-capitalist like didn't sell his
work mm kind of thing I don't think like
he doesn't sell his work like I remember
hearing a story about how someone had a
bunch of his work on display and they
were charging him to get in and he was
super unhappy about that
I don't know cuz you can buy prints over
the art and I'm sure money will go to
you yeah okay so well I don't know much
about him so nobody knows that's that's
what I think just had to blast you it
does alright so here you go
we built in a predator into this frame
and there you have it
years later sold for 1.4 million dollars
they're auctioning in pounds so it's
like that 4.4 million and the minute it
closes somebody with the remote
activated it who was there who knows had
a big eyes smile on his face it's a
shame it didn't complete it because they
were able to preserve it so that's why I
think like it's done so beautifully to
like the paper didn't get crumbled or
anything it's just like so his it so
again that's my question is about his
intention because I don't think his
intention was to destroy it because it
only shreds half and then it's done I
think it's a statement because she just
someone just paid a 1.4 million for this
the value since he did it yeah so now
not only is it available because I know
it was history yeah and now it's part of
his theory of art I mean it's pretty
cool that he pulled that off
I'm just confused about the message
because he increased the value and it's
not like he intentionally didn't destroy
the whole painting I don't care that
much and I don't think it matters not
much hmm I think it was still a cool
moment people were freaking out like all
of a sudden this paper is shredding
itself right well as possible it was an
intentional that it [ __ ] up like if he
really built this thing 10 years ago
yes malfunction I'm showing you that
this would raise the volume just cuz
that's how it goes I guess the moment
that never happened before so yeah I
mean it's brilliant
yeah it's brilliant that one baby waited
patiently for 10 years for this
beautiful moment or some idiot I don't
want call me an idiot I'll put it this
way Kurt Vonnegut I love this saying and
I'm not talking you can spend 10 20 30
ow
dollars on a piece of art I'm caught but
when you start spending like millions
you're paying for prestige right yeah
Kurt Vonnegut has this great quote he
says art is a conspiracy between the
rich and and like the and the art world
to make I said that's so bad yeah to
make poor people feel stupid art is a
conspiracy between rich people and
artists to make poor people feel stupid
because you see a painting sold for 20
million bucks and you're making $30,000
a year and you're like well [ __ ] no the
funny story is that some other guy who
owns a print shredded it more weight is
do we have a picture of that
that's so funny right we have us that is
hilarious was that a valuable print
before $40,000 so why the [ __ ] like what
did he take a scissor to it I'm not sure
oh here it is so I think that that was
intentional how it stopped right there
it's kind of still beautiful it is very
beautiful absolutely so what it was is I
mean he wasn't destroying someone's
purchase he was uh like I pray it was a
little okay bad chant of a gift everyone
freaked out it definitely ended up as a
gift I mean the guy who bought it had
the option to back out and he was like
[ __ ] no I want that yeah it's not like
but you remember mark McGrath what was
that guy's name the baseball player that
like broke the homerun record and the
Mark McGwire Mark McGwire sugar oh yeah
you're right sugar ray sugar right he he
broke the homerun record and the foul
ball hit into the stadium the guy who
caught it yellow sold it for 3 million
bucks yeah and then since everyone was
on steroids they kept breaking the
record like every year so lost all of
its value but this is that foul ball so
close that one oh and
okay so here here read that part today
my art broker calm received the seller
in Korea via website from someone who
has taken it upon themselves to shred
their own girl with balloon print in
order to increase its value
they have taken a piece of art worth Lee
ruff worth the forty thousand pounds and
in our opinion made its value one stupid
why would you I don't think there's
pictures of it I don't think they even
want to give that guy any attention
that's crazy to actually take a genuine
piece of art valuable art and just be
like oh I'm gonna [ __ ] cut it up now
like that's not how it works the seller
wanted them to list it as eighty eighty
thousand pound and they just disagreed
denied oh my god [ __ ] idiot
I bet you someone buys that though I'll
bet I'll bid $1 on it they says worth $1
I got a dollar so let's start the
bidding I mean that piece has history -
it's the idiot who cut up one you know
I'm saying I love it we've we've spent a
lot of money on art yeah but I'm maybe
like a couple thousand dollars which
you're basically paying for someone's
time and appreciation yeah first you
know twenty million dollars for a print
yeah I mean that's a big difference
I I appreciate art that I that I like
and I'll spend thousand bucks a couple
thousand bucks a hundred thousand
[ __ ] suck it's a lot depends like
this guy Robert uh Xavier has this huge
Batman I love it it's amazing I mean
that thing's I would guess worth a
hundred thousand but it's like the size
of this hole yeah you can I mean you
spent like ten thousand hours yeah and
like a whole house just for that but
anyway like there's some stuff like the
gold the Diamonds skull what was that
sold for like a hundred million million
dollars how rich and bored can
you be good now you could feed the whole
continent of Africa they're like nah
with the skull hmm they're like they're
like fix homelessness in your city
forever
now take the skull I'll take the skull
please
they're like cure cure HIV and AIDS in
all of Africa or one Diamond skull I'll
take the school Howard Stern had this
great bit where he went on the street
the Boston bomber he was like this
handsome young like air arab kid the
boston bomber and there was a lot of
girls who were like talk about how cute
he was and so they went on the street
with a picture of howard and a picture
of the boston bomber and they're like
which one would you rather date and
everyone was picking the Boston bomber
over Howard I love that so funny rather
date a terrorist than Howard I don't
think he was Arab by the way just for
the record oh god what was he I think I
think he was a Chechen Ian
I mean he was a Muslim he wasn't a Arab
correct okay my bad I stand corrected I
want to stand at my pulpit I want to say
I apologize all of my Arab brothers out
there who have been offended in this
unfortunate miss character Asian not all
not all Arabs are terrorists and that
was not what I meant to imply by any
means of any stretch of imagination he
was a Muslim young man of Chechen
descent which I believe is where's that
Dan well it's a region in southern
Russia and it's sort of an ongoing
called as thank you thank you very much
Dan for the clarification and please
everyone forgive me please and if you
think that you need to write an essay
about my mistake here today and expose
me please you have my permission I made
a grave error of judgment and I give him
full permission to make a 30-minute
essay about it as is entirely warranted
so apologies to everyone for that and
shoutout to to the essayist right now
Greece bans obese tourists from riding
on donkeys I love this it's [ __ ]
hilarious here's a fat lady on a donkey
Greece has banned fat tourists from
riding on donkeys after campaigners said
the animals were being left with spinal
injuries listen this isn't santorini
greece we've been there so we honey
little players I never once had the urge
to write a donk it's not really even
like a donkey friendly no I don't really
get that also if you look if you're fat
you got to give up some you got to give
some things up if you're a big [ __ ]
fatty and you're gonna break a donkey's
back then I mean you know what I'm
saying like there was a Nathan for you
about big horses and you could he had to
put like weather balloons on them and
[ __ ]
look don't howl what's the weight limit
how do they how do they define fat
because it just says fat I don't know
it's the other define it did this these
states uh donkey giving tourists rides
and scenery should not carry any loads
heavier than a hundred kilograms what
does that convert to see it sound like a
lot 220 pounds
so unless you're extremely tall and
built if you're over 200 wait what yeah
that's not a bad miss your weight I'm
too fat for it no I'm like at 195 that's
yo I'm too fat for a donkey what the
[ __ ] why do you need to write a Duncan
what kind of beast of burden is that now
I just did a complete 180 who's riding
these donkeys a little children yeah I
had a couple hamburgers in my life but
am I too fat to ride a donkey I don't
think so they're just little donkeys oh
they're not horses they're just trying
to save them going down the stairs so
do the stairs do some exercise no I need
a donkey ride I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
this donkey cause I'm so fat and the
break its back looking down more you can
see the stairs down more oh god these
poor people taking a neato fat people on
donkeys and they blurted but tiny bit
God he's not even enjoying himself that
donkey will never have another passenger
and you're not even enjoying yourself
that dog is gonna be put to sleep after
this and you're not even enjoying
yourself wait this says you have 100
kilograms well goddamn
there's more here you can't go that down
yourself oh wait we did do a donkey ride
no we did in centre a knee didn't we go
up a donkey's on those stairs or my fun
no ripping balls no way we did donkey
rides maybe I'm thinking of something
else how did we get up to the hotel by
car like the same yeah we go spor
donkeys man goddamn just poor
[ __ ] only bad Americans up and
down a hill incredible stuff man 60
minutes really stepped up the game dog
is a mayor oh we've got these fan
submissions but it's already been two
hours I'm coming or hour and a half
should we wrap it up this one's too
funny I'm gonna do this one I'm and it
guys send your questions comments essays
video suggestions to podcast at h3h3
productions calm I love it
this one was so funny from Joey Lewis he
says hey Ethan Aguila I listen to your
at number 87 podcasts where you
mentioned how semen can clog up the sour
drink this was relevant to me because
the freshmen housing at my school think
god I don't live there Ken Ken's Shaw
State they had to remove and replace the
plumbing for one of the buildings the
whole entire building due to the
build-up of semen tangling with hair
there's a photo of the notice that the
University Housing put up to reminds
just not to jerk off in the shower when
he said there is a photo I almost yeah
yeah yeah if you're not jerking off in
the shower where are you jerking off but
it's a communal shower
you got a jerk off responsibly Patrice
O'Neal had the greatest joke ever he
says I jerked off in the shower so many
times I'm swear as a little baby hasn't
called out dear residents we have
recently found several blockages in
plumbing system in University Village
Suites mostly caused by human hair let
me sit my water however over the last
month we have found many of these
blockages to be caused by large
quantities about we have now determined
to be semen this is intolerable
because semen is not soluble in water it
gets caught and filters and our system
and particularly susceptible this issue
has cost the university thousands of
dollars to repair thus far good thing
you collect a lot of tuitions and stop
complaining it's come out my semen
though we know that much though we know
that you must take care of your business
we have never faced a situation of this
enormity before it is because of this
unfortunately that we must ask you to
refrain from masturbating in the shower
may we those who wish to masturbate do
so in the comfort of their own bedroom
and dispose of their discharge
appropriately I bet you 90% of the dudes
continue to jack off in the show yeah I
love you better yet unlike motor labor
mm-hmm no signature this guy should
frame it no signature Joey
that's the tough thing how you can't
guarantee that second gotta stop me dude
I'm jerking off in the shower that's God
intended that's why school is so
expensive it's all the [ __ ] demon I
had a communal shower in college boy it
was Co sexual boys and girls shared the
same bathroom yeah I know yeah but there
was all the so you would come out with a
towel yeah yeah yeah there was a naked
beauty
yeah with a towel yeah but like there's
like four shower easels next to each
other with like occur and private stall
but yeah it was co-ed huh but there was
that you could there was semen on the
floor sometimes guys yeah there was a
bathtub in there by the way then nobody
you know but God forbid either you you
were in the military wasn't a co-ed
there are you [ __ ] kidding co-ed
everything I know about the military is
from Starship Troopers so I don't know
it it's separated the females we had our
own like little area and the male have
their own area even the Western Wall is
separated and therefore yeah I can
follow the US military's in co-ed
Starship Troopers
hey Dan I'll never forget that scene I
saw some titties that I didn't expect
showering I was like what enough [ __ ]
mm-hmm cuz I wasn't up I was like 13 so
if somebody like looked at me I like pop
a boner yeah I was like how did they
shower what there and they don't all
have fat boners right now remember when
you're 13 like you Tet you hit a speed
bump on the bus a little too fast you
pop a boner tuck it under the belt you
get really good at the the bass the
backpack masking method yeah you
checking something in your backpack I I
tucked it under the bell most of
time but sometimes because you have to
kind of maneuver for that and it yeah a
lot of tucking and grabbing right so the
backpack is definitely a godsend it's
one of the two options I don't think
there's anything else is there anything
else in or zach is there any other ways
you guys concealed boners and was like
sitting on the toilet when I was 13 that
was it what what you pop a bunny on the
toilet you mean you jerk off yeah you
didn't read the question where else have
you so you would [ __ ] and jerk off
interesting state would you sit first
would you jerk off after you [ __ ] you
would [ __ ] while jerking on so you sit
there stiff like this do you flush the
ball before you check off when you sit
over the [ __ ] so you flush and then you
jerk yeah there's still stinks probably
though yeah yeah I get you I smell my
own farts I'm ashamed a minute I love it
I love it I love it
yeah you wouldn't admit it you don't
like to smell your own farts not even a
little bit you're not intrigued no
you're not intrigued you're not
intrigued at least interested interested
in what the smell no that's like a
biological fact that people like to
smell their own fart like then Joey I
think so
you'd think Dan do you like the smell
Ralph I'm sorry
meaning we're out it's a fact and then
you finish to it I think so I was I
think this is another debate I think
people like to smell their own farm well
I will give you that I gotta tolerate it
for sure for sure I don't I savor you
smell it and enjoy it you deep you
breathe deeply on it you're just doing a
ya move I am NOT I like to smell my own
farts hey there's a lot of people out
there that agree so this is another one
of these things we need to explore and
I'm being genuine by the way I'm serious
why would I admit to that and by like
why would I lie about like in the Sonoma
being controversial goof I'm not even
wants desperately not to believe this is
what I'm hearing there was another one
somebody asked and the spirit of all
these conversations i D
zette zette zetz ler asked I was always
convinced everyone picks their nose
picking your nose ventilates it
effectively and enables you to breathe
much easier furthermore scraping a nice
dry chunk of snot out of your nose is
the best feeling ever to me it seems
like a basic human necessity but maybe
those are just my own habits ever since
you started these types of conversation
your podcast has said doubting my
judgment on what's normal and what is
not more and more so do you pick your
nose if so which finger to use also I am
pretty sure there are people who even
eat their boogers I am not sure whether
it is only kids or adults - personally I
always found it gross so I never did do
you so we're discussing like all the
taboo dude we're back normal tonight on
60 minutes
I think everyone picks their nose but
there's certain levels to it like if I'm
in the shower
like I find it gross mm-hmm so if I'm in
the shower that's a good place to pick
my nose
but generally I'll try to use a tissue
or something just because I
I just think it's kind of gross
personally but I think everyone picks
their nose yeah I tell you what's
grosser that I've seen people do you're
you're just walking with somebody on the
street and just out of nowhere without
saying anything
oh my god [ __ ] the word I'm like
you're just having a conversation and
make conversation
Sean Balog does that [ __ ] and then they
won't come out so they go on the street
with shredder the other day and if
someone's just walking on the cross the
street for me and they go why would you
do that in the sight of another human
being you lunatic some people think
that's normal okay that's [ __ ] wild
all right shit's crazy so picking the
nose I think I agree eating boogers is
[ __ ] up if you're under the age of
eight me boogers you're a [ __ ] weirdo
over but yeah actually you know what I
shouldn't say I don't wanna I never did
that's my personal preference I seen
some friends where I look over and
they're just like trying to like low-key
there but really what oh I don't want to
shame booger eaters because we're
whether we're getting out there we're
putting it all out there I think I do
think there's a large percentage of
adults they eat their boogers in secret
the idea to me is frankly repulsive yeah
why I don't think that watch like TV and
then anything is possible people like it
I don't know it's like smelling your own
fart to me that makes sense but eating a
booger makes me want to [ __ ] die the
innards AK I have to ask for posterity
do any of you guys pick your nose or eat
your books
I would rather lick dog poop what about
your home booger absolutely not
may I disgusting no never your life
he needs his own bug only gets the
skepticism I came in too dry too fast so
anyway that was interesting conversation
that's about it yeah about visit dog
becomes mayor's that's something
interesting or no dog became mayor what
you know there's this whole story about
a dog is getting re-elected as mayor and
what it made me think about is what does
this say about the job mayor I saw
people in the video say like you did
good like what does that mean he's a
good boy but being the mayor's a serious
job but you get paid like your
responsibilities like what does this say
about all government the mayor of LA is
a serious job yeah yeah but I think in
in smaller towns the mayor is like a
ceremonial thing like the City Council
really runs [ __ ] and then the mayor I
know this completely from Parks and Rec
so take this all the knowledge and
they're you know what they said it cost
a dollar to vote for the mirror yeah I
was like wow that's great
really no - Ron Ewan know about dollar
vote probably not that serious of an
election then it costs to vote that's
what I recall from the video we're not
gonna watch all right that's enough
thank you everyone who watched thank you
everyone who listened thank you everyone
who enjoyed I hope you're having a
blessed Friday hope you have a blessed
weekend thank you to everyone who's
taking notes diligently right now to
cast their essay on h3 productions and
how I've changed which is true I have
changed and so there's definitely
something there how I've compromised my
morals for money that's above either one
there's all the evidence there you can
pull from and yeah there's a lot there
so I will show the back yesterday we all
look so guys thank you all and and of
course using this clip and be
using this club and being like look how
he doesn't take criticism look how he
makes fun of the fact that he's just a
shill I look forward to that as well and
I think you for taking everything into
consideration my dear friends
have a blessed blessed weekend thank you
all so much and thank you all for
enjoying our new video that meant a lot
it was very nice to see ya
felt good it was a very wholesome
experience a very happy and and I'll see
you hopefully a lot of you tomorrow a
trip and dip yeah at our little
meet-and-greet looking forward to all of
that and so much more he was pregnant by
the way we had a whole thing but we hung
we had a whole thing about food you can
deli meats you have nine months to talk
about he looking at deli meats I was
like if ela can eat deli meats when she
was pregnant we all should not be eating
those that's freaky you know what I'm
saying but that's not how it works it's
not it's just it's sensitive today to do
a little pizza I the little peep of a
baby that it is right now yeah ouch our
songs almost over okay we better go
alright guys thank you all for watching
have a blessed weekend love you
appreciate you we'll see you next time
thank you so much